finishing off America that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
now we thought we'd reach across the
aisle tonight and try our hand at
jazzing up Biden's 2024 pitched the
voters
now first I was thinking the man needs a
campaign theme song doesn't he one that
reflects the energy that he brings to
the job every day
I don't need your rocking chair
[Music]
in my veins
this great hair don't mean to find
no not at all all right second President
Biden needs a message that promotes his
Stellar commitment to growth and
prosperity the reason I'm running again
is there's a job to finish the U.S gross
domestic product slowed to a 1.1 percent
annual rate in the first quarter
economists have been expecting a gross
of two percent Morgan Stanley expects
GDP to contract by 0.4 percent in Q2
look there's just there's more to finish
the job inflation is still too high here
and you've got interest rates that have
been going up for a year now a decrease
in inventory builds and inventory
Investments that's businesses cautious
and pulling back we have to finish the
job nail it down
now what down middle class workers
because under Biden they feel like
they're being crucified
if things do not improve the old Biden
voters are going to have to have a real
decision to make
it's not that easy is it in the end to
vote for decline to vote against your
own economic interests
well late tonight even the folks over at
Politico couldn't help but State the
obvious
writing unfortunately for Biden it's
very much not morning in America at
least from an economic perspective it's
more like late afternoon with the sunset
well I'll say especially since real
wages aren't keeping Pace with the
obscene cost of living
and workers they're losing hope as fast
as the White House is losing credibility
president believes that he needs to
continuing delivery to deliver for the
American people you hear us talk about
his economic policy has how that has
been able enabled him to build an
economy from the bottom up middle out we
are we're con we are going to do the job
and finishing up the agenda that he laid
out in 2020.
bottom up hollowed out
well their agenda that she's referencing
can be summed up in the acronym
SPD scarcity poverty and depravity
learn to live with less travel less
expect less lower the bar for everyone
including the administration
because they speak to us as if we're
deaf dumb and blind like we don't
actually experience the misery that
their policies have created across the
board
our country is back on track our
children are back in school people are
working the economy is coming along
infrastructure is being built Broadband
is being delivered we have rescued this
economy our veterans are now back being
taken care of Joe Biden has put us to
where we need to be and I think we need
to keep it going
keep it going where toward the Cliff's
Edge
by the way did he say the kids are back
in school it's like three years after
the pandemic was declared my friend now
they're not finishing the job here
they're finishing off us off by
demoralizing millions of Americans who
don't want special handouts they don't
want special pronouns and they're even
punishing those who work hard and play
by the rules
now the left has always when I was
thinking about this today they've always
been threatened by American
exceptionalism
where everyone is held to high standards
they don't like that
and now the Democrats have jumped on
board fully on board the victim train
where hard work and talent often go
unrecognized and unrewarded and if you
don't have the right skin color the
right ethnicity or political ideology
forget about it
so their idea of finishing the job means
creating a world where your carbon
footprint will be measured and your
social media presence scrutinize for
Dangerous misinformation hence critical
thinking and media literacy as a
mechanism to strengthen resilience to
misinformation and disinformation we're
also working to counter disinformation
and disinformation can lead some
individuals to violence or to voting
against you
now they certainly can't campaign on
these things this is just ridiculous we
all know that who would vote for this
instead it's all happy talk in the face
of depressing economic news
it's weekend at Biden's playing on a
continuous loop
the president is just an amazing leader
and has an incredible economic vision
and agenda and that is a vision to
rebuild our economy so that everybody's
included and nobody's Left Behind it's
just unbelievable what we are
accomplishing under the president's
leadership the facts speak for
themselves
you see how she was reading the screen
when she was speaking I mean does she
really act like she believes that
well Politico is noting that the economy
is unwell with recession worries
building across the financial industry
and overwhelmingly the consensus is that
the economy will struggle this year with
more than a dozen big banks in recent
weeks forecasting little or no growth
now remember the Mensa members in
Biden's Financial team they waved off
recession concerns as they were blowing
trillions of dollars and are now
shoveling hundreds of billions out the
door to Ukraine
now fit chair Jerome Powell is so lame
newly released video shows that he was
pumped by a few Russian pranksters who
called Powell pretending to be zelinski
in Powell talking on the phone to them
told them that most forecasts call for
the U.S economy to grow but at a pretty
subdued level so growth of less than one
percent let's say we would tell you that
a recession is almost as likely as very
slow growth well I'm glad he's honest
with a fake zielinski so here comes the
Biden recession he knows it and we know
it
and to think that it was just five years
ago when under Trump America was on a
roll I am thrilled to announce that in
the second quarter of this year
the United States economy grew at the
amazing rate of
4.1 percent and America is winning again
because we are finally putting America
first
everywhere we look we are seeing the
effects of the American economic marital
but today American citizens see that
Biden's team isn't focused on raising
their standard of living
instead the Biden team is focused on
remaking the country where illegal
immigrant dreamers are valued over
native born Americans
imagine if American workers saw their
incomes double in the past three years
so the economic debate between the two
parties it's largely over we know that
Biden's policies are going to fail and
keep failing and we know that the
policies of trump and of DeSantis they
work they grow jobs they increase wages
they make home ownership more not less
desirable
but the opposite is happening under
Biden no wonder the Biden White House
would rather talk about anything and I
mean anything other than the economy
heck Biden even gets stopped by kids
these days
do you watch the Stanley Cup playoffs
and if you do do you have a favorite
team
I did and I do
Philadelphia Flyers
whoops the Flyers didn't come close to
making the playoffs Joe but expect a lot
more of these frivolous fluffy little
events from now until election day now
by contrast Trump hit the economic
nightmare hard today in New Hampshire
with real solutions about how to start
turning things around
under the Trump reciprocal trade act
companies factories and jobs will come
roaring back into our country and
massive deficits that we've been paying
for decades and DEC it's going to
disappear I will also revoke China's
most favored nation Trade Center I will
gain total independence from China
oh music to my ears now States like
Texas Florida South Dakota Tennessee
they were run by smart Republican
Governors they voted for Trump because
they knew that Biden would do just what
he's done wreck the economy fling open
the Border push radical social policy
and leave a huge opening for China it's
all happened
the outcome of 2024 and that election is
going to depend largely on how many of
those Suburban women how many of those
Independents who supported Biden last
time how many of those hate Republicans
so much that they will choose more
economic pain over a return to
prosperity and Common Sense
my friends let's not finish off America
let's finish off socialism and stupidity
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else